When Dave was turning his life around and trying different things and figuring out what to do next, one of the places he looked was to the Howard Stern Show. And I think that was a really good choice.
当戴夫（Dave）试图改变人生，尝试各种新鲜事物并思考下一步该做什么时，他求助的地方之一就是霍华德·斯特恩（Howard Stern）的节目。我觉得那是个非常明智的选择。
I know everybody is not a fan of Howard Stern, but I am. And I think that one of the best things about the show is that it's always been a place where people talk with this kind of brutal and funny honesty about themselves. One of Howard's innovations is that he took the strain of crude, dark, confessional comedy that's always been a big part of stand-up, ever since Lenny Bruce-- Howard figured out a way to turn that into radio, daily radio.
我知道并不是每个人都喜欢霍华德·斯特恩，但我喜欢。我认为该节目最棒的一点在于，它一直是一个人们能以那种残酷而滑稽的坦诚来谈论自己的地方。霍华德的创新之处在于，他汲取了自莱尼·布鲁斯（Lenny Bruce）以来单口喜剧中那种粗俗、阴暗且带有忏悔性质的特质，并想出了一种将其实现在日常广播中的方法。
Anyway, to get back to this guy Dave, he loved that about the show. And in 2015, he was a few months sober, in his early 40s, working as a waiter at Katz's Deli in New York City. When he was younger, he'd worked in television, hosting an interview show for college kids but ruined that career with heroin addiction.
总之，回到戴夫这个家伙身上，他非常喜欢该节目的这一点。2015年，四十出头的他已戒毒几个月，在纽约市的卡茨熟食店（Katz's Deli）当服务员。年轻时，他曾在电视行业工作，主持过一档针对大学生的访谈节目，但后来因海洛因成瘾毁掉了那份事业。
Now sober in recovery, he needed a project. And he decided to a podcast about drugs with the feeling of the Howard Stern Show. Like, he remembered the years when comedian Artie Lange was on Howard Stern-- definitely my favorite period of Howard Stern.
如今在康复中，他需要一个项目。他决定做一档以药物为主题、带有霍华德·斯特恩节目风格的播客。他记得喜剧演员阿蒂·朗（Artie Lange）在霍华德·斯特恩节目组的那些年——那绝对是我最喜欢的霍华德·斯特恩时期。
When Artie would come on every day. He would talk about his own drug problems. He would tell crazy stories. He would talk in this very real way about the mistakes he was making in his life at that time that he was not able to stop, and Dave wanted to shoot for that. He would co-host the show with his friend Chris who-- he had met Chris years before in rehab.
阿蒂每天都会上节目。他会谈论自己的药物问题，讲述疯狂的故事。他会以一种非常真实的方式谈论他当时在生活中所犯的、无法停止的错误，而戴夫也想朝着这个方向努力。他将与好友克里斯（Chris）共同主持这档节目，他多年前在康复中心遇到了克里斯。
They would spend hours in rehab smoking cigarettes and talking about the crazy things that they'd done on drugs. That's what they wanted the podcast to be. People'd come on, tell wild drug stories, and-- very important to Dave-- no recovery talk, which Dave found to be sanctimonious and annoying.
他们在康复中心花了数小时抽烟，谈论他们在吸毒时做过的疯狂事。这就是他们希望播客呈现的样子。人们会来讲述狂野的药物故事，而且对戴夫来说非常重要的一点是，没有关于康复的话题，因为戴夫觉得那些话虚伪又烦人。
This show is not necessarily about recovery.
这个节目不一定与康复有关。
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
It's about drugs.
而是关于药物。
Maybe eventually it will be who knows.
也许最终会有关吧，谁知道呢。
If this show is ever about recovery, you got to get somebody else in this spot. I'm out.
如果这个节目要谈康复，你得找别人来做。我退出。
OK, in case this isn't clear. In these recordings, Dave is the one with the deeper voice and the loud opinions, Chris is the other guy.
好的，为了防止没说清楚。在这些录音中，声音较深沉、意见较响亮的是戴夫，另一个人是克里斯。
This show is about drug stories. It's not about recovery. It's not about doing the next right thing. It's about the last wrong thing.
这个节目讲的是药物故事，不是关于康复，也不是关于做接下来的正确之事，而是关于最后那件错事。
But maybe with the evolution of your recovery, that's what the show will become.
但也许随着你康复进程的发展，节目会变成那样。
Notice how at the end there, Chris is not agreeing with Dave. Chris is 10 years younger than Dave, but started drugs and drinking at an earlier age-- he was just 11 or 12-- and has way more extreme stories about it, including a year in prison. He's also spent way more time in rehab.
注意看，最后克里斯并不赞同戴夫。克里斯比戴夫小10岁，但更早就开始吸毒和酗酒——那时他才11或12岁——关于这些他有更极端的经历，包括坐了一年牢。他在康复中心待的时间也长得多。
And at this point, he'd been sober for nearly two years versus four months for Dave. And all of that gave him a different feeling about recovery and sobriety. He was game to talk about it, but Dave was adamant. Sobriety isn't all that entertaining. And first and foremost, he wanted the podcast to be entertaining.
此时，他已经戒毒近两年，而戴夫才四个月。所有这些让他对康复和清醒有了不同的感觉。他愿意谈论这个话题，但戴夫态度坚决。清醒本身并没有那么有趣，而他首先希望播客是好玩的。
If this show was about recovery, it's going to be lame.
如果这节目讲康复，那肯定很无聊。
So they'd tell drug stories. It wasn't meant to be good for you. It was meant to be fun. They listed it in the comedy section of iTunes, not self-help. If you want self-help, Dave had said, go to a meeting.
所以他们讲述药物故事。这本来就不是为了让你变得更好，而是为了娱乐。他们把它列在iTunes的喜剧类目下，而不是自助类目。如果想自助，戴夫曾说过，去参加互助会吧。
They were going to call the show War Stories, but there was already a podcast called War Stories. It was about actual war with tanks and guns and stuff, so they came up with Dopey, which really captures the spirit of the show perfectly. As Chris put it, two dopes talking about dope.
他们原本打算把节目叫《战争故事》（War Stories），但已经有个播客叫这个名字了。那是讲关于坦克、枪支之类的真实战争，于是他们想出了《Dopey》，这完美捕捉到了节目的精神。正如克里斯所说，两个瘾君子（Dope）在谈论毒品（Dope）。
Listen, I am so grateful to be sober. And I'm so grateful to be able to talk about drugs, you know, like in a way where I'm not feeling bad about it. It's not even euphoric recall. It's just funny.
听着，我非常感激自己能保持清醒。我也很感激能谈论毒品，以一种不感到难过的方式。这甚至不是什么欣快回忆，纯粹是好笑而已。
And I think that's why we got along, 'cause we felt safe doing that with each other. You know, sometimes you feel a little judged with people when you recount funny stuff that's happened to you.
我觉得这就是我们合得来的原因，因为我们在彼此面前感到安全。你知道，有时候当你讲述发生在自己身上的趣事时，你会觉得被别人评判。
Yeah.
没错。
In Dopey, there's going to be no judgment of drug use, past or present. They recorded the first episode on a laptop, no microphone or anything, near a fish tank in Dave's apartment in Manhattan. Maybe you could hear the hum of the tank in that recording. But between this episode, Episode 1 and Episode 143 of Dopey-- just 2 and 1/2 years later-- their lives are going to change drastically.
在《Dopey》里，不会对过去或现在的吸毒行为进行评判。他们在曼哈顿戴夫公寓的一个鱼缸旁，用一台笔记本电脑录制了第一集，没有麦克风或其他设备。也许你在那段录音里能听到鱼缸的嗡嗡声。但在这一集、第一集和第143集之间——仅仅两年半后——他们的生活将发生剧变。
By Episode 143, Dopey would sound completely different. In the episodes in between, they chronicle this story where so much happens to them and some others, things lots of drug users face. But because podcasts and radio are so intimate, it all gets documented in the most unfiltered way.
到第143集时，《Dopey》听起来将完全不同。在中间的这些集里，他们记录了一个故事，其中发生了很多事，涉及他们和一些其他人，这些都是许多吸毒者会面临的问题。但因为播客和广播是如此私密，这一切都以最不加修饰的方式被记录了下来。
Dave and Chris wanted their show to be just for fun, but it ended up being so much more. Today, we're going to have two stories like this. Stories about a kind of DIY radio-- very different kinds of DIY radio-- but in both stories, it's amateurs inventing how to talk about what it is that they're going through.
戴夫和克里斯原本只想做个纯娱乐节目，但它最终成了更多东西。今天，我们将讲述两个这样的故事。关于某种DIY广播的故事——虽然是非常不同类型的DIY广播——但在这两个故事里，都是业余人士在发明如何谈论他们正在经历的一切。
And really, both stories are dispatches from two very different battlefields. I know that sounds a little grand, but really this story-- from the opioid epidemic-- and then the other story is from a small town in Syria, in the middle of the war that's going on there. And we hear about life during that war in this way that is much more personal and close up than we usually get. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
实际上，这两个故事都是来自两个截然不同的战场的前线报道。我知道这听起来有点夸张，但确实，一个故事来自阿片类药物流行危机，另一个来自叙利亚战争中的小镇。我们以一种比平时更贴近、更个人化的方式听到了战争中的生活。来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act One, Two Dope Kings. So OK, you remember the premise? Two guys-- Dave and Chris-- they have this podcast. It's called Dopey. Dana Chivvis from our staff, listened to dozens of hours of the podcast, spanning 2 and 1/2 years, and tells the story of what happened.
第一幕，两个毒品之王。好吧，还记得前提吗？两个家伙——戴夫和克里斯——他们有个播客，叫《Dopey》。我们团队的达娜·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）听了数十个小时的播客，跨度两年半，并讲述了后来发生的故事。
Quick warning before we start, since this is the podcast internet version of our show, we have removed the bleeps that we use when we do the show on the radio. If you prefer a bleeped version of the show, it's at our website. Now here's Dana.
开始前有个快速警告，因为这是我们节目的播客互联网版，我们去掉了在电台广播时使用的消音提示音。如果你更喜欢消音版，可以在我们的网站上找到。现在有请达娜。
We've been talking about this podcast for five minutes already. And the whole point of the podcast is to tell crazy drug stories, so let's get right to one. This is from the very first episode. Chris tells the story.
我们谈论这个播客已经五分钟了。而播客的全部意义在于讲述疯狂的药物故事，所以我们直接来一个。这是第一集里的。克里斯讲的故事。
So I relapsed. I don't even want to say I relapsed. I just started using again after a brief period of abstinence. And I took a lot of Xanax-- about 60 bars-- for those of you that know bars.
所以我复吸了。我甚至不想说我复吸了。只是在短暂的戒断期后我又开始用了。我吃了很多赞安诺（Xanax）——大约60片（bar），对于那些知道bar是什么的人来说。
At once?
一次吃掉？
No, over a period of about three or four days.
不，在大约三四天的时间里。
So you took 120 milligrams over four days?
所以你在四天内吃了120毫克？
Yeah, and I blacked out for about a week. And during that blackout, I robbed a veterinarian. I went into the veterinary clinic. I told them my cat was having seizures and I needed phenobarbital ASAP. They told me something like, you know, we don't just hand out medications for the asking. Please fill out some paperwork and can we see your cat? Obviously, I had no cat with me.
对，我断片了大约一周。在断片期间，我抢劫了一家兽医诊所。我走进诊所，告诉他们我的猫在抽搐，我需要尽快获得苯巴比妥。他们说了一些话，大意是，我们不会随随便便把药物给别人。请填一下表格，让我们看看你的猫？显然，我没带猫。
Did you have a cat at home?
你家里有猫吗？
I did have a cat at home, Smegal.
家里是有只猫，叫斯米戈尔（Smegal）。
[LAUGHING]
[笑声]
So I fill out the paperwork. And while I was filling out the paperwork, I ended up putting it down and storming into the back, knocked over the nurse. And the veterinarian came into the medication storage room and tried to stop me.
所以我填了表格。在填表时，我把它放下，冲进了后台，撞倒了护士。兽医跑进储药室试图阻止我。
I got out. The police came. I struggled with the police and fought them, and got a bunch of assaults on the police officers. There was a helicopter on the scene. It was a big, big deal.
我逃了出来。警察来了。我和警察发生了肢体冲突，还袭警了。现场还有直升机。这事闹得非常大。
And just so you know something about Chris-- he's burly. Chris is at least six feet. He's like one of these Massachusetts Protestant white guys. He's very big and broad. And I would be scared if Chris got upset.
为了让你了解克里斯——他很魁梧。他至少六英尺高。他就像那种马萨诸塞州的白人清教徒大个子。如果克里斯生气，我会害怕的。
But I'm a gentle person.
但我是一个温和的人。
Very gentle, very gentle soul-- like a lamb.
非常温和，非常温柔的灵魂——就像羔羊一样。
If Chris is the lamb in a drug addicts clothing, Dave is the border collie, constantly circling Chris, herding him between drug stories, nipping at his ankles. For his Boston accent--
如果克里斯是穿着瘾君子外衣的羔羊，戴夫就是那只边境牧羊犬，不断绕着克里斯转，把他从药物故事中赶回来，咬他的脚后跟。关于他的波士顿口音——
Oh you invite all your Facebook friends to like Dopey.
哦，你邀请了你所有的Facebook好友来点赞《Dopey》。
No, I invite certain ones.
不，我只邀请了某些人。
Certain?
某些？
Certain--
某些——
Which certain ones do invite up to your room?
你邀请了哪些人到你的房间？
Room--
房间——
I invite certain friends up to my room.
我邀请了某些朋友到我的房间。
Or for Chris's vaping habit--
或者关于克里斯的电子烟习惯——
What's the flavor?
是什么口味？
This flavor is the milk inspired by Momofuku.
这个口味是受Momofuku启发的牛奶味。
Ugh-- this fucking vaping-- it's the end of the world and it's--
呃——这该死的电子烟——这是世界末日，而且——
Chris, on the other hand, comes across as a sweet docile kind of dope who finds subtle ways to subvert Dave's alpha maleness. Like on episode 15, it's as easy as the word toodles.
另一方面，克里斯表现得像个甜美温顺的瘾君子，他总能找到微妙的方法来颠覆戴夫的雄性领袖气质。比如在第15集，就像“再见”（toodles）这个词一样简单。
OK, toodles.
好了，再见（toodles）。
No, no, no, we don't say toodles.
不不不，我们不说toodles。
Which Dave hates, so Chris starts saying it at the end of every show.
戴夫讨厌这个词，所以克里斯开始在每集结尾都说。
All right, toodles.
好了，再见。
Please stop staying toodles.
请别再说了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
They do very little editing, except they do bleep out people's last names. They want the show to be anonymous, which is why I'm not using last names either, by the way. And they use nontraditional bleeps like this one.
他们的剪辑很少，除了会消掉人们的姓氏。他们希望节目保持匿名，顺便说一下，这也是我不使用姓氏的原因。而且他们会用非传统的消音效果，像这样。
[LASER SOUND]
[激光声]
Dopey is not the kind of show you bring home to meet your parents. Dave and Chris swear a lot, for one thing. And obviously they're talking about heavy drug use. But it's not just that-- they can be insensitive and insulting too.
《Dopey》可不是那种你会带回家见父母的节目。首先，戴夫和克里斯满嘴脏话。显然，他们谈论的是严重的吸毒问题。但不仅如此——他们有时也很麻木和侮辱人。
It is not politically correct by design. They use the kind of language you might forgive your grandfather for using, but which is harder to stomach coming from a 30 or 40 year old today. And then sometimes there's also language you wouldn't forgive your grandfather for using. I'm not going to play you that stuff.
这个节目刻意不追求政治正确。他们使用的语言可能是你会原谅爷爷那种人说的，但换作现在的30或40岁的人说出来就更难让人接受了。而且有时还有一些你甚至连爷爷都不会原谅的言论。我不会给你们播那些。
On the first few episodes of Dopey, they run through most of their favorite drug stories-- how Chris made wine from orange juice at rehab, how Dave once stayed up all night doing coke, heroin, and ecstasy before appearing on Howard Stern. How Chris shot crystal meth while at a brain injury clinic.
在《Dopey》的前几集里，他们讲遍了他们最喜欢的药物故事——克里斯如何在康复中心用橙汁酿酒，戴夫如何曾经通宵吸食可卡因、海洛因和摇头丸，然后去上霍华德·斯特恩的节目。克里斯如何在脑损伤诊所注射冰毒。
They're not supposed to be engaging in recovery talk, but of course, the only reason Dopey can exist is because Dave and Chris are both in recovery. There'd be no Dopey without it, so recovery keeps slipping into the conversation. Even Dave does it.
他们本不该进行康复话题的谈话，但当然，因为戴夫和克里斯都在康复中，《Dopey》才得以存在。没有康复，就没有《Dopey》，所以康复话题总会悄悄溜进谈话里。连戴夫也难免。
We're actually in a hurry, because I have to go qualify at an Alcoholics Anonymous meeting at 8:00.
我们实际上很赶时间，因为我得在8点去参加一个匿名戒酒互助会。
Yeah, it's a live episode of Dopey basically.
是啊，这基本上就是《Dopey》的直播集。
Basically, but more based on the recovery end of things. I'm a little bit nervous about it.
基本是，但更多是基于康复方面。我有点紧张。
Are you?
是吗？
Yeah, just let it rip. Don't even think about it, that's the best way to do it.
是啊，顺其自然吧。别多想，那是最好的方式。
Chris actually has a scholarly knowledge of 12 step philosophy. And now and then, he quotes by memory from the big book, which is sort of the Bible of Alcoholics Anonymous.
克里斯实际上对十二步哲学有学术级的了解。时不时地，他还会背诵摘录自《大书》（Big Book），那差不多是匿名戒酒互助会的圣经。
And then they added the appendix to the book where they quote William James, who says that you have a spiritual experience of the educational variety. That's what you're talking about. And it's actually--
然后他们在书后加上了附录，引用威廉·詹姆斯的话，他说你会有一种教育性质的灵性体验。这就是你所说的。实际上——
In the beginning-- for the first 20 episodes or so-- they get like 500 downloads an episode-- so barely an audience, but they start hearing from people right away. They get their first fan email from some guy named Troy three weeks after they upload the first episode. They can't believe anyone is listening to them. They call their newfound audience The Dopey Nation.
起初——在前20集左右——他们每集只有约500次下载——几乎没有听众，但他们很快就开始收到人们的回馈。在上传第一集三周后，他们收到了第一个粉丝邮件，来自一个叫特洛伊的人。他们不敢相信有人在听他们。他们称这些新发现的听众为“Dopey Nation”（瘾君子国民）。
Other people start emailing, leaving reviews on iTunes. Some listeners leave voicemails with their own war stories. Their downloads grow. By October, they average about 1,000 downloads an episode.
其他人开始发邮件，在iTunes上留下评论。一些听众留下了语音留言，分享他们自己的战争故事。下载量开始增长。到了十月，他们每集的平均下载量约为1000次。
So whoever The Dopey Nation is now, stay strong Dopey Nation.
所以不管现在的Dopey Nation是谁，都要保持坚强。
There's a Reddit thread about Dopey. A few people even get Dopey tattoos with the show's logo and the word Toodles underneath it. One guy takes Dave and Chris out to a steak dinner. He tells them he didn't get sober until he started listening to their show.
Reddit上有一个关于《Dopey》的帖子。一些人甚至纹了《Dopey》的纹身，上面有节目的标志和下面“Toodles”这个词。有一个人请戴夫和克里斯吃了一顿牛排晚餐。他告诉他们，直到开始听他们的节目，他才成功戒毒。
Dave and Chris try to write back to every email they get. They respond to comments on Facebook and Twitter. People aren't turned off by the recovery talk. They like listening to sober guys having fun, enjoying life in recovery. It gives them hope. Chris says the listeners come for the debauchery and stay for the recovery. He calls his marketing strategy rope a dope.
戴夫和克里斯尽量回复他们收到的每一封邮件。他们回应Facebook和Twitter上的评论。人们并没有被康复话题劝退。他们喜欢听这些保持清醒的人玩乐，享受康复中的生活。这给了他们希望。克里斯说听众是因为放荡不羁而入坑，因为康复而留下。他称这种营销策略为“借力打力”（rope a dope）。
Dave and Chris know they have a finite number of drug stories between the two of them, so they develop a roster of recurring guests, friends of theirs who are also sober-- near celebrities like Rob Reiner's son, Nick, Dave's dad Alan, and then there's a guy named Todd, one of Dave's best friends from college.
戴夫和克里斯知道他们两人手头的药物故事是有限的，所以他们开发了一个常驻嘉宾名单，都是他们也是处于康复中的朋友——比如罗伯·莱纳（Rob Reiner）的儿子尼克（Nick）、戴夫的父亲艾伦（Alan），还有一个叫托德（Todd）的家伙，戴夫大学时最好的朋友之一。
They got addicted to heroin together in their 20s. Dave always said if Todd got sober, he could be the third host of Dopey, and Todd really wants to be on Dopey, but Todd is never sober.
他们在20多岁时一起沉迷海洛因。戴夫一直说如果托德能戒毒，他就可以成为《Dopey》的第三位主持人，托德也非常想上节目，但他从不保持清醒。
All right, well if you want a good story, you know who to call here.
好吧，如果你想要个好故事，你知道该找谁。
Yeah, if you give me six months sobriety time and you're on the show.
是啊，只要你保持六个月清醒，你就上节目。
What?
什么？
Yeah.
是的。
I'm still full of stories. What are you talking about? I'm fucking full of 'em.
我还是有很多故事的。你在说什么？我TMD全是故事。
He's doing community service and stuff. He's giving back.
他在做社区服务什么的。他在回馈社会。
Please, he's giving back, but what-- you know-- just give me some fucking clean time and you can come back to the house.
算了吧，他在回馈，但什么——你懂的——只要给我些该死的清醒时间，你就可以回屋子里来。
I've got two weeks clean already.
我已经清醒两周了。
That's a lie. That's a lie.
那是谎话。那是谎话。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交叉谈话]
What do you want from me? [INAUDIBLE] more than two weeks. It's been two and a half weeks.
你到底想从我这得到什么？[听不清]不止两周。是两周半。
Since you've puffed weed?
从你吸大麻开始算？
No, no, since I did dope. I smoked weed three days ag-- no, two, three days ago.
不，不，从我吸毒开始算。我三天前……不，两天，三天前吸了大麻。
You're such a fucking liar.
你真是个该死的骗子。
Todd is one of the few recurring guests still actively using drugs. His life is in shambles. He's 42 and he can't hold down a job. He spends all his money on drugs, lives in his parents' apartment in Manhattan. He often just watches DVDs all day.
托德是极少数仍在主动吸毒的常驻嘉宾。他的生活一团糟。他42岁了，无法维持一份工作。他把所有的钱都花在毒品上，住在曼哈顿父母的公寓里。他经常整天就是看DVD。
How you doing Todd?
你好吗，托德？
Miserable, how you guys doing? [LAUGHS]
很痛苦，你们呢？[笑]
That's Chris talking to Todd on Episode 54.
那是克里斯在第54集和托德交谈。
I'm doing all right. Miserable--
我还行。很痛苦——
Not that good.
不太好。
Miserable-- is that related to substance abuse?
很痛苦——这和药物滥用有关吗？
Um, prob-- everything is related to substan-- what's not related to substance abuse these days?
嗯，可能——一切都和药物滥用有关——这些天有什么不是和药物滥用有关的？
Uh, less in my life.
额，我生活里少些。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
On this episode, Todd tells a very dopey story about getting so high on heroin, he passed out in a subway station and then slept through a meeting at the unemployment office the next day.
在这一集里，托德讲了一个非常“Dopey”的故事，说他吸海洛因吸得太高，在地铁站昏倒了，第二天错过了一场失业救济办公室的面试。
The call failed.
通话失败了。
Towards the end of this story, the call drops and Dave says--
在这个故事快结束时，电话断了，戴夫说——
Dude, that's the worst story I ever heard in my-- I thought it was fun for a second, and then I realized poor Todd is in big trouble.
伙计，那是我听过最烂的故事——我以为它有一秒钟是好玩的，然后我意识到可怜的托德陷入了大麻烦。
As a listener, to me it seems like Todd has a specific purpose on Dopey. He's a caricature of how not to treat your addiction, an example that Dave and Chris can hold up to their listeners and say, don't do it like this guy.
作为一个听众，我觉得托德在《Dopey》中有一个特定的目的。他是一个关于如何处理成瘾的反面教材，一个戴夫和克里斯可以拿出来给听众看并说“别像这家伙那样做”的例子。
When Dave and Chris talk about recovery, they often talk about abstinence and 12 step programs. That's what worked for them, but the science shows that opioid addiction is best treated with medications like suboxone and methadone, which are associated with a 68% decrease in death.
当戴夫和克里斯谈论康复时，他们经常谈论禁欲和十二步项目。那是对他们有效的方法，但科学表明，阿片类药物成瘾最好用丁丙诺啡（Suboxone）和美沙酮等药物治疗，这些药物与死亡率降低68%有关。
For a while on Dopey, Dave was pretty clear that he thought medications were dangerous, that you should learn to live without any substances. Chris was more middle of the road. Dave's opinions have changed by now. He feels like whatever works best for you is what you should do.
在《Dopey》有一段时间，戴夫很明确地表示他认为药物很危险，你应该学会没有物质也能生活。克里斯则比较中立。现在戴夫的看法已经改变了。他觉得无论什么对你最有效，你就应该怎么做。
Less than a year into making Dopey, Dave moved out of the apartment with the fish tank and in with his partner Linda and their six-year-old daughter. Chris eventually moved to Boston and started working towards a doctoral degree in psychology.
在制作《Dopey》不到一年时，戴夫搬出了那个有鱼缸的公寓，和他的伴侣琳达（Linda）以及他们六岁的女儿住在一起。克里斯最终搬到了波士顿，开始攻读心理学博士学位。
He was dating a med student named Annie. They lived together, had a dog. He was also working part-time for his sister's company-- which helps people who are struggling with addiction and other issues find treatment-- and he was working every other weekend at a sober living house.
他在和一名叫安妮（Annie）的医学生约会。他们住在一起，养了一条狗。他还为他姐姐的公司兼职——帮助那些正在努力应对成瘾及其他问题的人寻找治疗——而且他每隔一个周末在一家戒毒生活中心工作。
By episode 96 of Dopey, they're getting about 3,000 listeners a show. They decide to relabel the show. They move it from the comedy section on iTunes to the self-help section, mainly because they thought they could compete better against other self-help podcasts, rather than comedy podcasts, but also because by now they've admitted to themselves they are, in fact, a self-help show.
到《Dopey》第96集，他们每集有大约3000名听众。他们决定重新定位节目。他们把节目从iTunes的喜剧区移到了自助区，主要是因为他们觉得相比喜剧播客，他们在自助播客中更有竞争力，也因为此时他们已经向自己承认，他们实际上就是一个自助节目。
But anyway, back to Todd. On Dopey, Todd is the foil to the sober good life, to their successes. Where he lacks control, Dave and Chris now exercise restraint. Where he is depressed, they are content. Where he can't hold down a job, they're raising children, getting advanced degrees, making a podcast every week.
但无论如何，回到托德身上。在《Dopey》里，托德是那个清醒美好生活、他们成功的对照物。他缺乏控制力的地方，戴夫和克里斯现在行使节制。他抑郁的地方，他们感到满足。他维持不了工作的地方，他们养育孩子、攻读高级学位、每周制作播客。
Do something good for yourself tomorrow. Just do something.
明天为自己做点好事。做点什么就行。
I'll try.
我会试的。
Just-- nah, just do something. One thing and--
只是——不，就做点什么。一件事，然后——
I will.
我会的。
--it all builds on each other, right?
——这一切都是建立在彼此之上的，对吧？
Right on.
说得对。
Whatever, all right, bud. I love you.
不管怎样，好了，兄弟。我爱你。
All right, guys. You Chris, Dave have a great evening.
好的，伙计们。克里斯，戴夫，祝你们晚上愉快。
All right, thanks for calling Todd.
好的，谢谢你打电话来，托德。
All right, you got it, boys, I'll talk to you later.
好的，你们懂的，伙计们，回头聊。
All right, bud, bye.
好的，兄弟，再见。
Bye.
再见。
Bye, peace.
再见，和平。
That's tough. Sad, sad, call.
那很难。悲伤，悲伤的电话。
Hello?
喂？
Yo.
哟。
What's going on?
怎么了？
What's up, dude?
发生什么了，兄弟？
On Episode 126 last March, Todd's on the show again. This time though he's sober. He's been to detox and moved into a sober living house. He refused to go to rehab, so Dave and Chris arrange for him to move into the sober house where Chris works in Western Massachusetts.
在去年三月的第126集，托德又上了节目。但这一次他清醒了。他参加了排毒治疗并搬进了戒毒生活中心。他拒绝去康复中心，所以戴夫和克里斯帮他在克里斯工作的马萨诸塞州西部找了一个戒毒生活中心。
You sound terrible.
你听起来很糟糕。
Did you just wake up?
你刚醒吗？
No, I've been up for hours-- too many hours.
没，我已经醒了几个小时了——太多个小时了。
Oh turn that frown upside down Todd, this is the first really sober call on Dopey.
哦，托德，转忧为喜吧，这是《Dopey》上第一次真正清醒的通话。
That's Dave. He keeps saying how nice it is to talk to Todd when he's sober. He's happy to have his friend back, lucid. Dave tells him he bought some new equipment for Dopey-- a soundboard and three microphones, an extra for when Todd is back.
那是戴夫。他一直在说当托德清醒时和他聊天是多么美好。他很高兴朋友回来了，神志清晰。戴夫告诉他自己为《Dopey》买了新设备——一个音控台和三个麦克风，多出的那个是为了托德回来准备的。
Dude, I bought a board that was smaller, but it could only have two mics. And I was thinking, well, what do we do when Todd gets home? [LAUGHTER] So I went out and I bought another board-- the Todd board. [LAUGHTER]
兄弟，我买了个台子，它比较小，但只能接两个麦。我当时就在想，那托德回来时我们该怎么办？[笑声]所以我出去买了另一个台子——托德台。[笑声]
Yeah, all right, good. Thank you, I like that. I like that a lot.
是啊，好吧，很好。谢谢，我喜欢这个。我非常喜欢。
Dude, do you remember? You remember when you and me were driving home from LA--
兄弟，你还记得吗？记得你和我从洛杉矶开车回来时——
Todd lasted a few months at the sober living house, but he got bored and one day he left. Moved back in with his parents, got a job. And then in June--
托德在戒毒生活中心待了几个月，但他觉得无聊，有一天他离开了。搬回了父母家，找了份工作。然后在六月——
For those of you who don't know, this week was a terrible week for me. My very, very, very, very, very close friend Todd, who was on Dopey-- anyway, Todd died a week ago yesterday, so maybe eight days ago. He died. We don't know what happened, but I'm going to guess it was an overdose.
对于那些不知道的人，这一周对我来说太糟糕了。我非常、非常、非常、非常、非常亲密的朋友托德，那个上过《Dopey》的人——不管怎么说，托德昨天死了，所以也许是八天前。他死了。我们不知道发生了什么，但我猜是药物过量。
Yeah.
是的。
And I'm very broken up about it.
我对此感到非常心碎。
Todd died in his parents' house. He was 44 years old.
托德死在他父母的房子里。他44岁。
Well, I told my friends-- I told my friends he died. And they said, well, he's basically the most likely candidate to die. And I agreed with them, but like, it's so sad to me that he never gets to be sober and he never gets to be free. He's never free.
好吧，我告诉了我的朋友们——我告诉朋友他死了。他们说，嗯，他基本是最有可能死的人选。我也同意他们的观点，但，他永远没机会清醒，永远没机会自由，这让我感到非常悲哀。他永远不会自由了。
It's like, if you're out there and you think you're going to get away with it, you might not. You know what I mean? And like, you guys should really fucking know that it could all end.
就像，如果你还在外边，以为自己能侥幸逃脱，你可能逃不掉。你懂我意思吗？你们这些家伙真的TMD该知道，一切都可能随时结束。
Somehow after 20 years of heavy drug use, Dave had never had a close friend die from an overdose. Todd is his first one. It changes things for him.
在20年大量吸毒后，戴夫从未有过亲密朋友因药物过量死亡。托德是第一个。这对他改变了很多。
Before, he'd laugh at the war stories-- all these absurd situations and bad decisions that should kill you, but didn't. He'd had the upper hand, but now he didn't anymore. Those things had killed one of his best friends.
以前，他会嘲笑那些战争故事——所有这些本该杀死你却没杀死的荒谬情况和错误决定。他曾经占据上风，但现在不是了。那些事情杀死了他最好的朋友之一。
Dave is the one who introduced Chris and Todd. They weren't close friends, but even still, Dave thinks Chris is a little cold about his death. And Dave knows this is unfair, but he feels a little resentful towards Chris. Todd was in Chris's sober living facility right before he died. Why didn't he look out for him better?
戴夫是介绍克里斯和托德认识的人。他们不是亲密朋友，但即便如此，戴夫还是觉得克里斯对他死后的反应有点冷漠。戴夫知道这不公平，但他对克里斯感到有点怨恨。托德在去世前就在克里斯工作的那个戒毒生活中心。为什么他不能更好地照看他？
Todd's death last summer just happens to coincide with an uptick in downloads on Dopey. In July, their downloads double when they land their biggest celebrity interview yet-- Artie Lange, the comedian who inspired Dopey.
托德去年夏天的死正好与《Dopey》下载量的上升相吻合。七月，当他们请到了迄今为止最大的明星嘉宾——启发了《Dopey》的喜剧演员阿蒂·朗（Artie Lange）时，他们的下载量翻了一番。
This is the guest. I don't want you to know who I am yet because we'll let them guess. It's not Meryl Streep.
这是嘉宾。我不想让你知道他是谁，因为我们要让他们猜。不是梅丽尔·斯特里普（Meryl Streep）。
He's Episode 140, just two episodes after Todd's death. Artie tells a bunch of stories about getting high-- on The Howard Stern Show, on an airplane, in a Santa suit.
他是第140集的嘉宾，就在托德死后两集。阿蒂讲了一堆关于吸毒的故事——在霍华德·斯特恩节目上，在飞机上，在圣诞老人服装里。
So I'm Santa Claus-- the next morning, if you hit the beard, all this cocaine would come out of the beard.
所以我扮成圣诞老人——第二天早上，如果你敲胡子，所有的可卡因都会从胡子里掉出来。
He's a little unhinged during the interview, possibly high.
他在采访中有点失控，可能吸了毒。
What do I say?
我该说什么？
Stay strong Dopey Nation.
保持坚强，Dopey Nation。
Stay?
保持？
Stay strong, Dopey Nation.
保持坚强，Dopey Nation。
Stay-- the autumn wind is a pirate--
保持——秋风是个海盗——
Here we go.
开始了。
--bustling in from the sea. With a rollicking song, he tramples along, swaggering boisterously.
——从海上匆忙赶来。带着欢快的歌声，他大步走过，趾高气扬。
On the next episode of Dopey, Episode 141, Dave and Chris are on Skype. They do an Artie recap. Chris, whose drug of choice was always cocaine, thinks Artie was probably on cocaine. They talk about it for 30 minutes before Dave changes the subject.
在下一集《Dopey》，第141集，戴夫和克里斯在Skype上。他们做了一个阿蒂的总结。克里斯，他的毒品首选一直是可卡因，觉得阿蒂可能吸了可卡因。他们讨论了30分钟，然后戴夫换了话题。
Two weeks ago, I'm at work--
两周前，我在工作——
Yeah, I know where you're going with this.
是啊，我知道你要说什么了。
Where he's going is, Dave wants to do a little recovery lesson. Two weeks before, Chris had made a phone call to his sponsor and it was clear he thought he was talking to Dave, so the sponsor got worried and called a friend of Chris's who texted Dave, who freaked out.
他要说的是，戴夫想做一个小康复课程。两周前，克里斯给他的赞助人打了个电话，很明显他以为他在和戴夫说话，所以赞助人很担心，给克里斯的一个朋友发了短信，那人又发给了戴夫，把戴夫吓坏了。
And then I'm like, holy shit, so I start texting you.
然后我就像，该死，我开始给你发短信。
You texted me so many-- I took a screenshot of it. You texted me like 12 times in ten minutes or something.
你发了太多——我截了图。你在十分钟内发了12条还是什么的。
Chris is one of those people who always texts back, even if he's sleeping. So when Dave didn't hear from Chris, he sent a message to Annie, Chris's girlfriend. Chris eventually resurfaced and calmed everyone down, but he was ticked that Dave had contacted Annie. He was fine, just a little sleepy and out of it. No reason to scare his girlfriend.
克里斯是那种总会回短信的人，即使他在睡觉。所以当戴夫没收到克里斯的消息时，他给克里斯的女朋友安妮发了条信息。克里斯最终出现了并让大家冷静下来，但他对戴夫联系安妮感到很生气。他很好，只是有点困和神志不清。没必要吓唬他女朋友。
--everything happened and I got upset. There's just that it had to come back to Annie. And I never would get upset if somebody expressed concern.
——一切都发生了，我很沮丧。只是这件事非得扯到安妮身上。如果有人表达关心，我永远不会生气。
Well, that's not true. You get upset when I'm concerned all the time.
好吧，那不是真的。你一直都会因为我的关心而生气。
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
[交叉谈话]
--you take concern as a personal attack.
——你把关心当作人身攻击。
How often do you text me, are you OK?
你多久发短信问我一次，你还好吗？
I'm concerned.
我很担心。
You do it like every five minutes.
你每五分钟就做一次。
This was just two weeks after Todd died, so Dave was admittedly on high alert. And by the end of the story, he sees it from Chris's perspective. It's one of those irritating things that happens to people in recovery. You act slightly off one day and everyone assumes you're using again. Dave explains.
这离托德去世才两周，所以戴夫坦言处于高度戒备状态。故事讲到最后，他从克里斯的角度看了问题。这是康复中的人们会遇到的令人恼火的事情之一。你某天表现得稍微有点不对劲，每个人就假定你又在吸毒了。戴夫解释说。
The point of this story-- obviously, you're fine. The point of the story is this is something that addicts have to go through who are using, who are lying. You know what I mean?
这个故事的重点——显然，你很好。重点是这是正在吸毒、正在撒谎的瘾君子必须经历的事情。你懂我意思吗？
Like, they're covering up their shit or they just got clean and everybody is sure that they're still getting high. Or in your situation-- you know, you're 4 and 1/2 years clean, but like, how do you think somebody should deal with that? Because I bet there's a ton of people listening with very little--
就像，他们掩盖自己的破事，或者他们刚戒毒，每个人都确信他们还在吸毒。或者在你的情况下——你懂的，你已经戒毒4年半了，但你觉得别人该怎么处理这种情况？因为我打赌有很多听众几乎——
The next week they do Episode 142. Normally they record the show on Friday night and Chris puts it online on Saturday morning. But that Friday, Chris gets home from a work trip to Texas and he's too exhausted to record the show. They agree to do it Saturday.
接下来的一周他们做了第142集。通常他们周五晚上录节目，克里斯周六早上上网。但那个周五，克里斯从德州的出差回来，太累了，没法录节目。他们同意周六录。
Saturday comes around and Chris is fighting with Annie. He tells Dave he's too upset to record the show. He needs to go to the gym. Then after the gym, he needs another hour.
周六到了，克里斯在和安妮吵架。他告诉戴夫他太沮丧了没法录。他需要去健身房。健身房出来后，他还需要一小时。
Dave's getting pissed. He knows The Dopey Nation is expecting an episode. They finally start recording late that night, around 11:00. Chris is lackluster.
戴夫开始气炸了。他知道Dopey Nation在期待一集节目。他们终于在深夜11点开始录。克里斯状态平平。
Dave's doing most of the work, providing most of the energy. And Chris keeps screwing up and saying things that they later have to bleep out, like where he went on the work trip or his sister's name, or Dave's last name.
戴夫做了大部分工作，提供了大部分能量。克里斯不断搞砸，说出一些他们后来必须消掉的话，比如他去哪出差、他姐姐的名字，或者是戴夫的姓氏。
It's amazing that Bob [INAUDIBLE] is driving round and thinks, you know who I should talk to? Dave [BLEEP].
令人惊奇的是鲍勃[听不清]开车绕了一圈，心想，我知道我该和谁谈？戴夫[消音]。
Why'd you say my last name? Now you have to bleep it.
你为什么说我姓？现在你得消音了。
Ah, fucking A. Let me put it in my notes. It doesn't even work because we've changed it so much. [BLEEP] Now it's twice. And what else?
啊，TMD。让我记在笔记里。这都没用，因为我们改了太多次。[消音] 现在两次了。还有别的吗？
What is wrong with you?
你这人怎么了？
I don't know. I'm stupid. I can't-- [BLEEP] [BLEEP] --was. I said it once, right?
我不知道。我太蠢了。我不能——[消音][消音]——当时。我说了一次，对吧？
Ah, Chris.
啊，克里斯。
What?
什么？
How are we going to get the show out?
我们怎么把节目播出去？
I'll do it tonight.
我今晚就做。
Dave's worried that Chris has lost interest in Dopey, that he's too busy with the other things in his life now-- his girlfriend, his job, his doctorate. He starts wondering if Chris is going to quit. And if he does, what will happen to the show? They finally sign off at 1:00 in the morning.
戴夫担心克里斯已经对《Dopey》失去了兴趣，他现在太忙于生活中的其他事情了——女朋友、工作、博士学位。他开始怀疑克里斯是否要退出。如果他退出了，节目会怎么样？他们最终在凌晨1点结束了通话。
And stay strong, my brothers and sisters, in and out of recovery. And toodles, I'm going to stop the call recorder. You can stay online. All right?
保持坚强，我的兄弟姐妹们，无论是在康复中还是康复外。Toodles（再见），我要关掉通话录音了。你可以保持在线。好吗？
Hey, but you don't have to say toodles. It's unnecessary.
嘿，你不必说toodles。没必要。
Toodles.
Toodles。
So hello and welcome to Dopey, the podcast about drugs, addiction, and dumb shit. And I am Dave.
你好，欢迎来到《Dopey》，关于毒品、成瘾和蠢事的播客。我是戴夫。
This is the next episode of Dopey, Episode 143-- a week later.
这是《Dopey》的下一集，第143集——一周后。
For those who aren't on Dopey social media, the worst thing that could have ever happened, happened, and Chris relapsed and died. And here I am alone at my dad's with one microphone plugged into the mixer.
对于那些不在《Dopey》社交媒体上的人，发生了一件史上最糟糕的事情，克里斯复吸并死了。现在我一个人在我爸那里，麦克风连着混音器。
Chris overdosed three days after Episode 142. He'd been secretly using drugs again, probably for weeks. After that last episode they recorded together, Dave and Chris fought.
克里斯在第142集三天后过量死亡。他一直在秘密复吸，可能已经几周了。在他们一起录制的最后一集之后，戴夫和克里斯吵了架。
First, Chris put the show online without bleeping out Dave's last name. Dave was pissed. He went in and fixed it, but inadvertently inserted 10 minutes of silence into the middle of the episode, which made Chris mad. So that Monday they're fighting over text message all day.
起初，克里斯没消掉戴夫的姓氏就把节目上网了。戴夫气炸了。他进去修复了它，但无意中在中间插入了10分钟静音，这让克里斯很生气。所以那个周一，他们整天都在吵短信。
Dave couldn't make sense of what was going on with Chris. He told Chris it was fine if he didn't want to do Dopey anymore. But Chris said no, that wasn't it at all. He loved making Dopey. Dave believed him.
戴夫无法理解克里斯到底怎么了。他告诉克里斯如果不想再做《Dopey》也没关系。但克里斯说不，根本不是那样。他热爱做《Dopey》。戴夫相信了他。
But meanwhile, Chris was also fighting with Annie. She'd left their apartment and went to stay with her parents. Chris was distraught, crying. He asked Dave to call and check in on him, so Dave called him after midnight and told them he'd check in again in the morning, went to bed.
但与此同时，克里斯也在和安妮吵架。她搬出了公寓，去和父母住。克里斯很痛苦，在哭。他让戴夫打电话来看看他，所以戴夫午夜后给他打了电话，告诉他们明天早上会再看看他，然后睡觉了。
He woke up at 6 AM to a text from Annie. She'd sent it in the middle of the night asking Dave if he'd check on Chris. So at 6:30, Dave sent Chris a text message.
早上6点他被安妮的一条短信吵醒。她在深夜发来的，问戴夫是否看了克里斯。所以在6点半，戴夫给克里斯发了条信息。
A minute later, Chris wrote back, I'm good. As you like to hear, I'm sleeping, but not totally good. Alive, nothing to worry about. We can talk later. At 10:30, Annie called Dave and told him that Chris was dead.
一分钟后，克里斯写回：我很好。如你所愿，我在睡觉，但还没完全好。活着，没什么可担心的。我们可以稍后谈。10点半，安妮给戴夫打电话，告诉他克里斯死了。
In the next few days, Dave had to decide if he was going to do the show that week or ever again. In the 2 and 1/2 years of making Dopey together, they'd never missed a show. Dave thought if he skipped this week, he'd be letting The Dopey Nation down.
在接下来的几天里，戴夫不得不决定他是否还要在那周做节目，或者以后还要不要做。在一起制作《Dopey》的两年半里，他们从没错过一集。戴夫想如果这周不录，他就辜负了Dopey Nation。
It would be like your drug dealer not showing up. And besides, drug users should know if somebody dies from a drug overdose. So three days after Chris's death, he recorded that episode of Dopey. And he calls Annie.
那就像你的毒贩没出现一样。此外，吸毒者应该知道如果有人因过量而死。所以克里斯死后三天，他录制了那期节目。他打电话给安妮。
Hello?
喂？
Hey, you're on--
嘿，你在——
Hey, how are you?
嘿，你好吗？
You're on the show.
你在节目上。
Oh, ha-ha-- hello, everybody.
哦，哈——大家好。
How are you feeling?
你感觉如何？
Ah, pretty shitty.
啊，相当糟糕。
They start to piece together the mystery of Chris's death. Dave had completely misread his behavior. In retrospect, he was probably high on the last episode of Dopey. He was probably high when he made that weird phone call to his sponsor. He was probably even high on the Artie Lange episode.
他们开始拼凑克里斯死亡的谜团。戴夫完全误读了他的行为。回想起来，他在《Dopey》最后一集时可能已经吸了。当他给赞助人打那个奇怪的电话时，他可能已经吸了。他在阿蒂·朗那集时可能也吸了。
Dave had been operating off the wrong story-- that Chris wasn't interested in Dopey anymore, but Annie hadn't. She had noticed the strange ways Chris had been acting. He kept taking the dog for walks, for instance, when the dog didn't need to go out.
戴夫一直基于错误的故事——即克里斯对《Dopey》不再感兴趣了，但安妮没有。她注意到了克里斯表现出的奇怪方式。例如，他不断带狗出去散步，虽然狗不需要出去。
He was staying up all night and sleeping during the day. She got suspicious he was using again, so she and Chris's sister arranged for a surprise drug test. On Monday, a guy showed up at their apartment and did a saliva test.
他整夜不睡，白天睡觉。她开始怀疑他又在吸毒，所以她和克里斯的姐姐安排了一次突击药检。周一，一个人来到他们的公寓做了唾液检测。
That night, Annie told him she was going to stay with her parents. Chris left before her mom arrived to pick her up. Now she realized it was because he couldn't wait any longer to get high. Annie slept at her parents' house and went to work the next morning. But soon after, she went home to check on Chris.
那天晚上，安妮告诉他她要回父母家住。克里斯在她妈妈来接她之前就离开了。现在她意识到那是因为他等不及要吸毒了。安妮在父母家睡觉，第二天早上去了上班。但不久后，她回家看看克里斯。
And I don't know if you want me to elaborate on how it was walking into the apartment.
我不知道你是否想让我详述走进公寓时的情景。
Yeah, you might as well.
是啊，你也可以说。
Or would you rather I not.
还是你宁愿不要。
No, you might as well.
不，你最好说。
I walked in. The first thing I see is his shoes, so I figure, OK, he's here. And the vape is there, the keys are there, so I look at the couch. He's not on the couch. And I look at the bed, and he's not there.
我走进去。第一眼看到的是他的鞋子，所以我心想，好，他在家。电子烟在那，钥匙也在，所以我看沙发。他不在沙发上。我看了床，他也不在那。
And then I [INAUDIBLE] bathroom, I go into the bathroom. He's not there. And that's when I start panicking, and-- and as I walk into the bedroom, on the side of the bed, I found him dead.
然后我[听不清]洗手间，我走进洗手间。他也不在那。那时我开始恐慌，然后——我走进卧室，在床边，发现了他死了。
I knew right away he was dead. Everything after that is somewhat foggy. I knew we had Narcan at home, because he always kept Narcan everywhere.
我立刻就知道他死了。那之后的一切都很模糊。我知道家里有纳洛酮（Narcan），因为他总是到处都放着纳洛酮。
Narcan is a medication that can reverse an opioid overdose. You spray it up a person's nose.
纳洛酮是一种可以逆转阿片类过量的药物。你喷到人的鼻子里。
And I got the Narcan, but I knew it was too late. I just had to do it, because it was like the only thing I could do it at the moment.
我拿到了纳洛酮，但我知道太迟了。我不得不做，因为那是当时我唯一能做的事情。
Chris had cocaine, Xanax, alcohol, and fentanyl in his system. He was 33 years old. Soon after, a package arrived for him at their apartment. It was filled with drugs-- Percocet, cocaine, crack cocaine, heroin.
克里斯体内有可卡因、赞安诺、酒精和芬太尼。他33岁。不久后，一个快递送到公寓。里面全是毒品——Percocet、可卡因、快克可卡因、海洛因。
Annie scoured the apartment and Chris's car. She found a bunch of drug paraphernalia-- needles, some of which were used, and clean pee he'd ordered online. Also, she found a small medicated patch that wasn't in any packaging.
安妮搜索了公寓和克里斯的车。她发现了一堆毒品用具——针头，其中一些是用过的，还有她在网上买的干净尿液。此外，她还发现了一个没在包装里的小药物贴片。
She sent a picture of it to Dave. They couldn't be sure, but Dave thought it was probably fentanyl. Annie has a theory about Chris's relapse.
她把照片发给戴夫。他们不能确定，但戴夫认为可能是芬太尼。安妮对克里斯的复吸有一个理论。
He had recently injured himself doing a high karate kick to try to impress her. Something in his leg popped, he was in terrible pain.
他最近为了给安妮留下深刻印象，做了一个高踢腿，腿受伤了。腿里有什么东西断了，他疼得要命。
The doctor he saw wasn't his regular doctor and she thinks Chris got painkillers, fooled himself into thinking he could just take them for the pain and stop there. If Annie's theory is right, then Chris started using again two weeks after Todd's death and was dead three weeks later.
给他看的医生不是他固定的医生，她认为克里斯拿到了止痛药，自欺欺人地认为他可以只为了疼痛服用，然后停下来。如果安妮的理论是对的，那么克里斯在托德死后两周开始复吸，三周后就死了。
I mean, when the news came, I got angry about it. And then the next morning I woke up and-- you know, I felt the day between the last time I had spoken to him. You know what I mean?
我是说，当消息传来时，我感到很愤怒。第二天早上醒来，我感受到了上次和他说过话后的每一天。你懂我意思吗？
I felt the distance, and I was like, it just felt like it was becoming real. And then this morning I woke up, and I could hear his voice in my head like we were doing the show. I could hear his voice.
我感觉到了那种距离，我心想，这听起来正在变得真实。今天早上我醒来，能听到他脑子里的声音，就像我们在做节目一样。我能听到他的声音。
And then I kind of woke up and it was another day since I had spoken to him. And it just-- it's like liquid becoming solid. You know what I mean? And it's like, you move away from this liquid feeling to this cold solid truth that he is never going to come back and it's over.
然后我醒来，又离我上次和他说话过了一天。它就像液体变成了固体。你懂我意思吗？就像，你从这种液体的感觉转变成他永远不会回来、一切都结束的冰冷事实。
Dave hangs up with Annie. And now he's got to end this episode of Dopey without Chris for the first time.
戴夫挂断了安妮的电话。现在他必须第一次在没有克里斯的情况下结束这一集。
We'll just end it the way we always end it. And we'll say, stay strong Dopey Nation. And I said I would never say this, but Chris is dead, so I'll say toodles for Chris. And we love you. And everybody out there, please try to take care of yourself. All right.
我们就像往常一样结束它。我们说，保持坚强，Dopey Nation。我说过我永远不会说这个词，但克里斯死了，所以我要为克里斯说Toodles。我们爱你。在外面的每个人，请努力照顾好自己。好了。
Dave still makes Dopey-- by himself now. He's pulling in bigger guests like the comedian Marc Maron and the rapper Killer Mike. He gets about 6,000 downloads an episode now, but it's not the same show.
戴夫现在还在做《Dopey》——他一个人。他请到了更大的嘉宾，比如喜剧演员马克·马龙（Marc Maron）和说唱歌手Killer Mike。他现在每集大约有6000次下载，但这已经不是同一个节目了。
Dopey, as the nation knew it, is gone along with Chris. It's not a buddy comedy anymore. It's more of a straight interview show. There are fewer war stories, and when there are, the tone is different. Dave is different.
正如国民所知的《Dopey》随着克里斯一起消失了。它不再是兄弟喜剧了。它更像是一个纯粹的访谈节目。战争故事更少了，即使有，语气也不一样了。戴夫也不一样了。
There's this one moment in Episode 142, the last episode Dave and Chris did together, that I keep thinking about. Chris had just played a voicemail from a listener named Mike, who tells a story about hiding his pee in the closet of his bedroom. It's not important why. And afterwards, they get into a conversation about whether it's OK to laugh at drug stories.
在戴夫和克里斯一起做的最后一集第142集中，有一个瞬间我一直反复思考。克里斯刚播放了一段听众麦克（Mike）的留言，讲述了把尿藏在卧室衣柜里的故事。为什么并不重要。之后，他们开始讨论嘲笑药物故事是否可以。
In the first episodes of Dopey, Dave was a solid yes on that-- that was the whole point of the show-- but now they've flipped sides. Chris says yes, it's fine to laugh. And Dave says this--
在《Dopey》的第一几集里，戴夫对此是肯定的——这正是节目的全部意义——但现在他们变了。克里斯说可以，嘲笑是可以的。戴夫说——
I think it's funny, but the fucked up thing-- and it might be the end of Dopey, right? Check this out. Like, I just feel like this guy-- he's like everyone's laughing about everything they're doing. And then they can just drop dead.
我觉得它很好笑，但这TMD糟糕的事情——这可能是《Dopey》的终点，对吧？看看这个。就像，我觉得这家伙——每个人都在嘲笑他们所做的一切。然后他们随时可能突然倒地死去。
But what's the flipside? Morbid reality the whole time until you die?
但另一面呢？在你死之前一直处于病态的现实中？
No, dude. I think it's funny. I think the urine is funny. I think that shit is hysterical. But it's like laughing on the train tracks and not seeing the fucking train coming. I don't think morbid reality is better. No, of course not. I'm just saying it's sad, you know?
不，伙计。我觉得它好笑。我觉得尿液很好笑。我觉得那事简直歇斯底里。但就像在铁轨上欢笑，却没看到火车开过来。我不认为病态现实更好。不，当然不是。我只是说这很悲哀，你懂吗？
We laugh on the train tracks, but we have the right to laugh on the train tracks. It'd be much different if someone had never struggled. And the truth is that when we were struggling, the person who would tell a story that was terrifying and laugh at it, might have a better chance at reaching us and getting us to stop than the person who's morbid reality.
我们在铁轨上欢笑，但我们有权在铁轨上欢笑。如果是一个从未经历过挣扎的人，情况会大不相同。事实是，当我们还在挣扎时，那个讲述可怕故事还能嘲笑它的人，可能比那个只谈病态现实的人更有机会接触到我们并让我们停止。
I just feel responsible. I think it's obviously because of Todd's death that when we laugh at stuff, I just want to throw it out there that at any second, Mike could be dead. Because Mike's still using. And there's fentanyl everywhere. And it's killing everybody. That's what I'm saying. How's that?
我只是感到负责。我认为这显然是因为托德的死，所以当我们嘲笑东西时，我只是想抛出这个观点，即随时麦克都可能死。因为麦克还在用。到处都是芬太尼。它正在杀死所有人。这就是我说的。这怎么样？
Yes, no, of course. Yeah.
是的，不，当然。是的。
Dave told me, he always thought Dopey was good for him and Chris, for their sobriety. He thought their creation would protect them, but it didn't. Chris is gone. Dopey, it turns out, was its own war story, playing out week by week.
戴夫告诉我，他一直认为《Dopey》对他和克里斯的康复有好处。他认为他们的作品会保护他们，但并没有。克里斯走了。《Dopey》原来也是他们自己的战争故事，一周一周地展开。
So now on the show, Dave's mission has changed. The drug stories aren't just in service of a laugh now, they're in service of an urgent message. You could die. Todd died. Chris died. You could die.
所以现在在节目中，戴夫的使命改变了。药物故事不再仅仅为了欢笑，它们是为了服务于一个紧迫的信息。你可能会死。托德死了。克里斯死了。你可能会死。
Dana Chivvis is one of the producers of our show. The Dopey podcast, you can find it wherever you get your podcasts. Coming up, what happens when you go on the radio and make fun of a militant Islamist group who also happened to run your town, because you're in Syria. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
达娜·奇维斯是我们节目的制作人之一。《Dopey》播客，你可以在任何地方找到它。接下来，当你去电台嘲笑一个恰好统治了你所在城镇的激进伊斯兰组织，因为你在叙利亚，会发生什么。稍后继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show-- Wartime Radio. People in battlefields of one kind or another, using very DIY grassroots level radio or podcasting to try to make sense of what is happening around them. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，我们选择一个主题，带给你们关于该主题的不同故事。今天的节目——战时广播。身处某种战场的人们，使用非常自发的草根级广播或播客来试图理清周围发生的事情。我们到达了节目的第二幕。第二幕。
Good Morning, Kafrenbel. So back in my 20s, I was a volunteer reporter at a community radio station in Washington, DC-- WPFW, a great station, that really did reflect the community. DC was 2/3 African-American back then and also had immigrants from all over the world.
早上好，卡弗兰贝勒（Kafrenbel）。回到我20多岁时，我是华盛顿特区社区电台WPFW的一名志愿记者，一个伟大的电台，确实反映了社区。当时特区三分之二的人口是非裔美国人，也有来自世界各地的移民。
And the most popular show on the station, I remember, was the Bama hour. It was a guy named Jerry Washington who would play songs and talk a lot about his niece. There were Caribbean and Central American shows. There was a show made by Iranians who missed the former Shah of Iran. And then another show with Iranians who hated the former Shah of Iran.
我记得电台上最受欢迎的节目是“巴马小时”（Bama hour）。是一个叫杰瑞·华盛顿（Jerry Washington）的人播放歌曲，谈论很多关于他侄女的事。有加勒比和中美洲节目。有一个由伊朗人制作的节目，他们想念伊朗的前国王。然后另一个节目由讨厌伊朗前国王的伊朗人制作。
There was a call-in poetry show. Listeners would call in and read their own poems and it was daily. This was a daily call-in poetry show, that in my memory anyway, never seemed to have any kind of trouble getting callers. That's community radio.
有一个电话诗歌节目。听众会打电话进来读他们自己的诗，那是每天的。这是一个每天的电话诗歌节目，据我记忆，似乎从没遇到过找不到打电话的人这种问题。这就是社区广播。
Well, this next story is about somebody setting up a station like that-- a community station-- only they're doing it in a war zone, in Syria, in a small town called Kafrenbel. That's Kafrenbel, it's spelled with a K-- in the Northwest part of the country, not far from the Turkish border, rural town, surrounded by olive trees and fig trees, 30,000 people live there.
好吧，下一个故事是关于某人建立像那样的电台——社区电台——只是他们在战区，在叙利亚一个叫卡弗兰贝勒的小镇。那是卡弗兰贝勒，用K拼写——在该国西北部，离土耳其边境不远，农村小镇，被橄榄树和无花果树环绕，住着3万人。
And for almost eight years now, Kafrenbel's been in a kind of no-man's-land where different factions have fought. And now militant Islamists are in charge. Reporter Dana Ballout heard about the station years before she ever listened to it.
近八年来，卡弗兰贝勒一直处于不同派系争斗的某种无主之地。现在激进伊斯兰分子掌管着这里。记者达娜·巴卢特（Dana Ballout）在听这个电台的前几年就听说过它。
I crossed paths with the founder of the station back when I was covering the war in Syria for the Wall Street Journal. His name is Raed. Raed Fares. He lives in Kafrenbel.
当我在为《华尔街日报》报道叙利亚战争时，我曾与该电台的创始人擦肩而过。他的名字叫拉埃德（Raed），拉埃德·法雷斯（Raed Fares）。他住在卡弗兰贝勒。
We never met in person. I was based across the border in Lebanon, because American press was mostly not allowed in Syria. But when the regime struck a town near Kafrenbel or ISIS was advancing and I needed to know the details from the ground, me and my colleagues would pull out our giant spreadsheet of contacts and go through them. Raed's was one of those names. I'd Skype him to confirm a death count or verify a location, then move on.
我们从未见过面。我驻扎在边境对面的黎巴嫩，因为美国新闻界大多不被允许进入叙利亚。但当政权打击卡弗兰贝勒附近的一个城镇或者伊斯兰国（ISIS）正在推进，而我需要了解地面细节时，我和同事们会拿出我们巨大的联系人电子表格并过一遍。拉埃德的名字就在其中。我会通过Skype联系他以确认死亡人数或验证地点，然后继续。
Raed was an activist. Before the radio station, he was sort of famous for these banners, these homemade signs written in big block letters on white sheets. He would bring them to protests, post pictures of them on Facebook and Twitter. I always saw them in my feeds. They were witty, like this one from Thanksgiving, a holiday Syria does not celebrate.
拉埃德是一名活动家。在电台之前，他因这些横幅而闻名，这些印在白色床单上的大黑字手写横幅。他会把它们带到抗议活动中，在Facebook和Twitter上发布它们的照片。我总是在我的动态里看到它们。它们很诙谐，就像感恩节那天的那个横幅，叙利亚并不庆祝感恩节。
Black Friday special offer-- whoever, wherever you are, bring your enemy and come to fight in Syria for free. Limited time offer.
“黑色星期五特别优惠——无论你是谁，在哪里，带上你的敌人来叙利亚免费参战。限时优惠。”
One of the most viral of these was after Caitlyn Jenner announced her new name Caitlyn, spelled with a C and not a K like the other women's names in her family. Raed gave her this shout-out. Caitlyn, he writes spelling it with a C, we would write Kafrenbel with a C, if it meant, like you, we could be free.
其中最疯传的一个是凯特琳·詹纳（Caitlyn Jenner）宣布她的新名字凯特琳后，用C拼写，而不是像她家族中其他女性名字那样用K拼写。拉埃德给了她这个呼喊。凯特琳，他写道，用C拼写，“我们会用C拼写卡弗兰贝勒，如果这意味着，像你一样，我们可以自由。”
I knew Raed had his own radio station, Radio Fresh, though I never tuned in back then. But around Thanksgiving last year, I heard Raed had been killed. It hit me harder than I expected.
我知道拉埃德有自己的电台，“新鲜广播”（Radio Fresh），虽然那时我从没收听过。但去年感恩节左右，我听说拉埃德被杀害了。这比我预期的冲击更大。
Saddened by the news, I listened for the first time. You can stream Radio Fresh on SoundCloud. There's hours and hours of programming. Listening through was like reliving the war from the inside. Seeing it in a totally different way from deep in the small town.
对新闻感到难过，我第一次收听了。你可以在SoundCloud上流媒体收听“新鲜广播”。有数小时的节目。完整听下来就像从内部重温战争。以一种完全不同于深入小镇深处的方式看待它。
It was incredibly alive, hyper-local, sometimes utterly ordinary, people complaining about their neighbors. But other times, so radical I couldn't believe they got away with it. Here's an example of that. One of the first things I heard-- this satire program called [ARABIC] backstage with the president, where an actor impersonating president Bashar al Assad has made up conversations with an officer in his army.
它非常鲜活，超本地化，有时非常平凡，人们抱怨他们的邻居。但其他时候，如此激进，我无法相信他们竟然能逃脱惩罚。这是一个例子。我听到的第一件事——这个讽刺节目叫[阿拉伯语]“后台见总统”，演员扮演巴沙尔·阿萨德（Bashar al Assad）总统，杜撰了与他军队中一名军官的对话。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
That's the actor making fun of the president's lisp, which is very pronounced. He's pretty spot-on.
那是演员嘲笑总统的大舌音，非常明显。他模仿得非常到位。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
I was shocked when I first heard this impression. My knee jerk reaction was oh my god, how did you not go to jail for this? Because in the past, that's what would have happened.
我第一次听到这个模仿时感到震惊。我的膝跳反应是“天哪，你没因此坐牢吗？”因为过去，那正是会发生的事情。
Before listening to Radio Fresh, I had literally heard of two other places in the whole Arab world where anyone had tried to do political satire-- one was Lebanon, where I'm from, and the other Egypt, where for a while til the government ran him out of the country, they had their own version of Jon Stewart. And now there were these guys out of a small town in northern Syria. It completely blew my mind.
在收听“新鲜广播”之前，我真正在整个阿拉伯世界听说过两个尝试做政治讽刺的地方——一个是黎巴嫩，我的家乡，另一个是埃及，在那里曾有一段时间直到政府把他赶出国门，他们有自己版本的乔恩·斯图尔特（Jon Stewart）。而现在这些家伙来自叙利亚北部的一个小镇。这完全让我惊呆了。
I talked to a bunch of Raed's friends in Kafrenbel. They told me he was always a rebel. Before the uprising against the Syrian regime, he would curse the president in a way no one else dared. He mocked religious figures too.
我和拉埃德在卡弗兰贝勒的朋友们谈过。他们告诉我他一直是个叛逆者。在反对叙利亚政权的起义之前，他曾以无人敢用的方式诅咒总统。他也嘲笑宗教人物。
His cousin told me this always made people super nervous. Everyone in town knew him as the guy who got kicked out of med school. Raed was a burly guy in his mid 40s, clean shaven, warm eyes, mischievous face. He was sharp, taught himself English, ran a thriving small business.
他的表弟告诉我这总让人们超级紧张。镇上的每个人都知道他是那个被医学院开除的人。拉埃德是个40多岁魁梧的家伙，剃得很干净，眼神温暖，脸庞调皮。他很敏锐，自学英语，经营着一家蓬勃发展的小企业。
One of his best friends, Hadi Abdullah, told me how Raed started the radio station.
他最好的朋友之一，哈迪·阿卜杜拉（Hadi Abdullah）告诉我拉埃德是如何建立电台的。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
In our mosques, they have loudspeakers.
在我们的清真寺里，他们有扩音器。
These are the speakers for the call to prayer five times a day. At one point, early in the war, the Syrian military showed up in Kafrenbel and started shooting protesters. Raed wanted to get those soldiers to defect.
这些是每天五次礼拜呼唤的喇叭。在战争初期的某个时候，叙利亚军队出现在卡弗兰贝勒并开始射杀抗议者。拉埃德想让那些士兵投诚。
So he loaded up a bunch of recordings on a USB stick and had some friends at the mosque blast them over those speakers. Anti- regime slogans like--
所以他在USB存了一堆录音，让清真寺的朋友们通过那些喇叭播放出来。反政权标语如——
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
The regime is tricking you. The regime is using you. Regime is killing your family. There are no terrorists here, everybody is civilian here.
“政权在骗你们。政权在利用你们。政权在杀害你们的家人。这里没有恐怖分子，每个人都是平民。”
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
And the idea started from here. And I was like, why am I limiting myself to the mosque only. Why don't I start a radio station, where I could to just talk to people?
“这个想法从这里开始。我想，我为什么要限制自己在清真寺里？为什么我不建个广播电台，在那里我可以和人们谈话？”
So shortly after, when Raed found himself meeting with international groups, including the US State Department, he pitched them his idea for a radio station. There are always opportunities in war, and this one would be an unusual chance to push back on the rules, make fun of people they could have never made fun of before, an opportunity to blast out ideas like free speech and democracy to whoever tuned in to 90.0 FM.
所以没过多久，当拉埃德发现自己与包括美国国务院在内的国际组织会面时，他向他们推销了自己的电台想法。战争中总有契机，而这将是一个不同寻常的机会来抵制规则，嘲笑那些他们以前从未敢嘲笑的人，一个机会通过90.0调频频率向所有收听的人爆发出言论自由和民主的思想。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
This is a clip from the station's first few weeks on air, August 2013. Radio Fresh was based out of an old government building in Kafrenbel. The studio was done up with shiny purple curtains for soundproofing. There was an ashtray on the table and lots of smoking while they were on the mic.
这是2013年8月该电台开播最初几周的片段。“新鲜广播”总部设在卡弗兰贝勒的一栋旧政府大楼里。演播室装饰着闪亮的紫色窗帘以进行隔音。桌上有一个烟灰缸，录音时抽了很多烟。
The host, who's talking about how to form neighborhood councils, has a thick local accent. One of my favorite things about Radio Fresh-- it sounds rural, slangy, homegrown.
主持人谈论如何组建邻里委员会，带有浓厚的当地口音。我最喜欢“新鲜广播”的一点是，它听起来很农村、俚语化、本土化。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
While I was charmed by the station from the very first clip I heard, the people it was actually made for-- the citizens of Kafrenbel-- many of them were against it in the beginning. Here's Raed himself, on the second anniversary of Radio Fresh, one of the rare times he actually went on air.
虽然我从听到的第一个片段就被这个电台吸引了，但它真正为其服务的对象——卡弗兰贝勒的公民——许多人在开始时是反对它的。这是拉埃德本人，在“新鲜广播”成立两周年纪念日，他极其罕见地亲自上直播。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
He's saying, in the beginning, there was a lot of talk about how the money for the radio would have been better spent on aid for families in need. People were hungry. They didn't have clean water or electricity.
他说，起初，有很多人讨论说电台的钱如果能花在需要帮助的家庭援助上会更好。人们很饿。他们没有干净的水或电。
It seemed extravagant and frivolous to spend money on a radio show, but pretty early on, the station came up with a program that became indispensable throughout the village. It was called The Observatory. Radio Fresh put 24/7 watchmen in tall buildings to keep an eye out for air strikes.
把钱花在广播节目上看起来很奢侈和轻浮，但很快，电台想出了一个在村庄里变得不可或缺的节目。它叫“天文台”。“新鲜广播”在高大建筑里安排了24/7的守望者来观察空袭。
As soon as they saw one, they radioed into the station, which would interrupt programming on, say, the nutritional benefits of lettuce--
一旦他们看到，他们就用电台广播发出信号，中断节目，比如谈论生菜的营养价值——
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
[SIREN]
[警报]
--with an air raid siren.
——伴随着空袭警报。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
They're saying, planes are circling over Kafrenbel. Raed's response to the doubters was the radio isn't frivolous. It's about saving lives.
他们说，“飞机在卡弗兰贝勒上空盘旋。”拉埃德对质疑者的回答是，广播不是轻浮的。它是关于挽救生命。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
He's saying, if these airstrike warnings saved even one life, that would be worth the whole cost of the station. Before the observatory, people used to jerry-rig their own version of this alert system-- buying a walkie talkie and eavesdropping on the regime's frequencies.
他说，如果这些空袭警告哪怕挽救了一条生命，那也值得电台的全部成本。在天文台之前，人们习惯于自己搞这种警报系统的拼凑版——购买对讲机并窃听政权的频率。
It was expensive-- over $100. And parents hated how much the regime thugs would swear and cuss on the frequency. They didn't like that the kids overheard. The Observatory was a clean version for the cost of a basic radio-- $5.
它很贵——超过100美元。而且父母们讨厌政权暴徒在频率上咒骂。他们不喜欢孩子们听到这些。天文台是一个干净的版本，成本仅为一台基本收音机——5美元。
The air raid warnings-- they were just one of a slew of super practical, you live in a war zone and here's how to survive of programs. There was a medical show that teaches people how to administer first aid. That show has episodes on chemical burns, meningitis in kids, how to treat head injuries--
空袭警告——它们仅仅是一系列超级实用的“你生活在战区，这是生存方式”节目的其中一个。有一个医疗节目教人们如何进行急救。那个节目有关于化学灼伤、儿童脑膜炎、如何治疗头部损伤的剧集——
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
Here the host is saying when you think your skull is broken or when you see blood or a clear fluid coming from your ears or nose, get medical help immediately. Radio Fresh had language learning programs in case you had to flee the country.
在这里，主持人说当你认为颅骨骨折，或者看到血液或透明液体从耳朵或鼻子流出时，立即寻求医疗帮助。“新鲜广播”有语言学习节目，以防你不得不逃离该国。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
They're doing the alphabet in this episode of Teach Me Turkish. More than 3.5 million Syrian refugees have landed in Turkey the last eight years. They also taught French, English. And what I love about these programs is how the people teaching the language are actually not at all fluent in the language they're teaching, but you can hear how hard they're trying.
在这个“教我土耳其语”的剧集中，他们正在念字母表。过去八年里有超过350万叙利亚难民抵达土耳其。他们也教法语、英语。我喜欢这些项目的一点是，教语言的人实际上根本不流利，但你能听到他们有多努力。
Dear listeners, welcome to the 11th episode of Teach Me English.
亲爱的听众，欢迎收听“教我英语”的第11集。
Everyone I talked to about Radio Fresh brought up this one program, called the Complaints Show. It was Radio Fresh's version of a call-in show, except they couldn't actually have a call-in show, because the regime had cut off all the phone lines. So they put up a bunch of little black boxes with a Radio Fresh sticker on them, all around town. People would drop in slips of paper with their answers to quiz shows, their comments and complaints. The host would choose one complaint each week to talk about.
我谈到的每个关于“新鲜广播”的人都提到了这个叫“投诉节目”的项目。它是“新鲜广播”版本的电话连线节目，只是他们实际上没法做电话连线，因为政权切断了所有电话线。所以他们在镇上到处放了一堆带“新鲜广播”贴纸的小黑盒子。人们会塞进写有他们测验答案、评论和投诉的小纸片。主持人每周会选择一个投诉来谈论。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
Often, it's very specific stuff. At one point early on, a faction set up shop inside a school building, using it as a police station. Parents were worried about sending their kids to school in a building shared with criminals and thieves. Plus, the police station made the school an easy target for the regime.
通常，内容非常具体。早些时候，一个派系在学校大楼里设立了店面，将其用作警察局。父母们担心让他们的孩子去和罪犯及小偷共用大楼的学校。此外，警察局使学校成为政权的软目标。
Parents told the rebels their concerns, but nothing happened. So they turned to Radio Fresh.
父母们告诉反叛分子他们的担忧，但什么也没发生。所以他们求助于“新鲜广播”。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
Today, we have a complaint that there is a police station in the same building as a school, and that, the broadcaster says, defies logic. Again, here's Raed's friend, Hadi.
“今天，我们有一个投诉，说是学校大楼里有个警察局，那，”广播员说，“违背逻辑。”再次，这是拉埃德的朋友，哈迪。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
Some when the people inside the police station heard the episode on the radio, they came right away to us, and they told us, "we're willing to leave the school. Please, tell the families we're going to leave the place. We don't want any trouble against us." And they did. They emptied the police station from all the militants that were there.
当警察局里的人听到电台节目时，他们立刻来到我们这里，告诉我们，“我们愿意离开学校。请告诉家庭我们要离开这个地方。我们不想惹任何麻烦。”他们确实离开了。他们清空了警察局里的所有武装分子。
People complained about the price and quality of their bread. Someone brought up their neighbor using a hole in the front yard as a bathroom, while his actual bathroom was broken. The neighbor heard the episode and fixed his toilet. When I first heard the Complaints Show, it felt pretty familiar. We had a similar program in Lebanon, although not quite as small towny as the neighbor's toilet.
人们抱怨面包的价格和质量。有人提到邻居在院子里挖个洞当厕所，而他的实际厕所坏了。邻居听了这期节目并修理了他的马桶。当我第一次听到“投诉节目”时，感觉很熟悉。我们在黎巴嫩也有类似的节目，虽然不像邻居马桶那样小镇化。
But listening hour after hour, what I realized was that this Complaints Show was doing something besides solving practical local problems. It was also spreading a revolutionary idea, that you could voice your concerns, and hold people accountable, and get results. The guys at the station confirmed this was Raed's original mission for the show. This, in a place where the rules were so recently non-negotiable and you just had to keep your head down and deal with it. The Complaints Show was just one of the many programs, debates, kids shows, series on Islam doing this kind of work.
但听着一小时又一小时，我意识到这个“投诉节目”除了解决实际的局部问题，还在做别的事情。它还在传播革命思想，即你可以表达你的关切，让人们负责，并获得结果。电台的伙计们证实这是拉埃德做该节目的最初使命。这发生在一个规则最近才变成非协商一致、你只能低着头应付的地方。“投诉节目”仅仅是许多做这种工作的节目、辩论、儿童节目、关于伊斯兰系列的其中一个。
One problem people had with the station from the beginning was that it was funded by the Americans, which, in the middle of a war where the US was not being particularly helpful, was not a good look.
人们从一开始对电台的一个问题是，它是由美国人资助的，在战争中间、美国没怎么帮忙的时候，这看起来不太好。
It's true. Almost all the money for the station has come from the US State Department. It's around $40,000 a month these days, which covers the salaries of 53 people. It's a pretty big operation. When listeners accuse the station of being a mouthpiece for the Americans, Raed was happy to address it head on. This is him on the air.
没错。电台几乎所有的钱都来自美国国务院。这些日子每月大约4万美元，这覆盖了53个人的薪水。这是一个相当大的行动。当听众指责电台是美国人的传声筒时，拉埃德很高兴直接面对它。这是他在直播时说的。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
He says the response is very simple. Have you heard anything on Radio Fresh that sounds like we're supporting the Americans? We're always trying to prod them on the radio, with our banners. We have opinions about them, and we don't hide them. Raed's vision of democracy meant everyone in Kafrenbel had an equal say in what was happening, including women.
他说回应非常简单。你听到“新鲜广播”里有任何支持美国人的声音吗？我们总是试图在电台上用我们的横幅刺激他们。我们对他们有意见，而且我们不隐藏。拉埃德对民主的愿景意味着卡弗兰贝勒的每个人对发生的事情都有平等的发言权，包括女性。
He wanted their voices on the radio too. Although that was such a daring idea for Kafrenbel, even his friend Hadi wondered whether it was possible.
他也想让她们的声音出现在电台上。虽然对于卡弗兰贝勒这是一个如此大胆的想法，即使是他的朋友哈迪也想知道是否可能。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
And I was like, how? He was like, "Easy. You find women, we hire them, we train them."
我问，“怎么做？”他说，“容易。你找到女性，我们雇她们，我们训练她们。”
This was bold, because almost no women in the village worked outside the home. They took care of the kids and the homes. That was it. And it was bold because of who was running Kafrenbel at the time. Raed was always offending the local leaders, including just about everyone who was in charge of Kafrenbel over the last eight years.
这很大胆，因为村里几乎没有女性在户外工作。她们照顾孩子和家庭。就是这样。这很大胆，因为当时是谁在管理卡弗兰贝勒。拉埃德总是冒犯地方领导人，包括过去八年来负责卡弗兰贝勒的几乎每个人。
First, the Free Syrian Army was offended by a banner, so they came to the radio station and kidnapped two guys. Next, ISIS attacked the station in 2013. A couple weeks later, they shot Raed multiple times, almost killing him. But when Raed was deciding to put women on the air in 2015, two years after Radio Fresh had started, Kafrenbel was run by a new extremist Islamist group, Nusra, al-Qaeda's branch in Syria. Raed knew they wouldn't like this, but he went for it anyway.
起初，叙利亚自由军因一个横幅被冒犯，所以他们来到广播电台绑架了两个人。接着，ISIS在2013年袭击了电台。几周后，他们多次射击拉埃德，差点杀了他。但当拉埃德决定在2015年让女性直播时，那是在“新鲜广播”开始两年后，卡弗兰贝勒由一个新的极端伊斯兰组织，“努斯拉”（Nusra），基地组织在叙利亚的分支管理。拉埃德知道他们不会喜欢，但他还是做了。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
That's Hiba Abboud introducing the afternoon newscast. She's now the director of the women's division of Radio Fresh. She talked to me from the women's office over Skype.
那是希巴·阿布德（Hiba Abboud）介绍下午的新闻广播。她现在是“新鲜广播”女性部门的主任。她通过Skype从女性办公室和我谈话。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
I never imagined that I would hear my own voice, or that I would be a reporter. Never.
“我从未想象过我会听到自己的声音，或者我会成为一名记者。从没想过。”
Hiba was a young newlywed who had just moved to town when she heard that Radio Fresh was recruiting women to go on air. She'd been listening to the radio and was curious what it was like to make it. So she, along with 20 other women, went to the first training. They did icebreakers, spent three days on voice technique.
希巴是一名刚搬到镇上的年轻新婚女子，当她听说“新鲜广播”正在招募女性去直播时。她一直听电台，很好奇做电台是什么感觉。所以她和其他20名女性一起参加了第一次培训。她们做破冰游戏，花了三天时间练习声音技巧。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
I don't know if you know this one, but when you put your pen in your mouth, this is a way to open up your voice.
我不知道你是否知道这个，当你把钢笔放在嘴里时，这是打开声音的一种方式。
I did not know this one. Neither did most of the people at This American Life.
我不知道这个。在《美国生活》的大多数人也不知道。
And how to be as a presenter, and how to take breaths from your belly.
以及作为主持人该怎么做，如何从肚子呼吸。
Hiba passed the training and began working at the station, made news shows, programs about women's rights, interviews with local women who had lost their husbands in the war. By the time Raed put Hiba and the other women on the air in 2015, the Islamists in charge of Kafrenbel, Nusra, already hated Radio Fresh.
希巴通过了培训并开始在电台工作，做新闻节目、关于女性权利的项目、采访当地在战争中失去丈夫的女性。到拉埃德在2015年把希巴和其他女性送上直播时，卡弗兰贝勒负责的伊斯兰分子，“努斯拉”，已经恨透了“新鲜广播”。
The station poked fun at them in all sorts of ways. For being illiterate, hypocritical. One satire depicted their religious police rushing people to the mosque without actually understanding the rules of prayer. Nusra assigned people to listen to Radio Fresh in shifts. They issued regular warnings and threats to the station whenever they heard something they didn't like.
电台以各种方式嘲弄他们。因为文盲、虚伪。一个讽刺剧描写了他们的宗教警察在根本不理解礼拜规则的情况下把人们赶往清真寺。努斯拉指派人员轮班收听“新鲜广播”。只要听到他们不喜欢的内容，他们就会发出例行的警告和威胁。
Now Radio Fresh got a lot of warnings for having women on air. Nusra considered their voices shameful, a form of nakedness. Finally, in January 2016, Nusra had had enough. They burst in one morning to shut the station down, broke down the door, faces covered, carrying machine guns. They took everything-- laptops, the transmitter, Hadi's hookah, flash drives. Hiba and the other women watched the Nusra guys ransack the main station from another building, the women's office just up the hill.
现在“新鲜广播”因让女性直播而收到很多警告。努斯拉认为她们的声音可耻，是一种裸露。终于，在2016年1月，努斯拉受够了。他们一天早上冲进去关闭了电台，破门而入，蒙着脸，带着机关枪。他们带走了一切——笔记本电脑、发射机、哈迪的水烟、闪存驱动器。希巴和其他女性在另一栋建筑里从女性办公室看着努斯拉的人洗劫主电台，办公室就在山上。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
And we looked out the window when we heard a lot of noise. So us girls, we just started gathering everything and hiding it. Because we said, you know, they were going to come to us next.
我们听到很多噪音时向窗外看。所以我们女孩，我们只是开始收集所有东西并隐藏它。因为我们说，你知道，他们接下来会来找我们。
They quickly rearranged the office to make it look more like a home.
她们迅速重新布置了办公室，让它看起来更像一个家。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
So we were preparing lies, you know, just in case that came in and they started questioning us. And you know, we were going to say like, "Oh, we're just girls here hanging out at her house, and we're just having breakfast together. A morning coffee or a mate.
所以我们在准备谎言，你知道，以防他们进来开始质问我们。你知道，我们要说，“哦，我们只是女孩聚在一起，我们只是在一起吃早餐。晨间咖啡或马黛茶。”
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
But they just took the stuff and they left. They didn't even come to us.
但他们只是拿了东西就走了。他们甚至没来找我们。
Nusra blindfolded Raed and took him to the infamous al-Uqab Prison. They left two armed men at the station to keep anyone from coming in. Every day, Hiba would finish her housework and get dressed to go in for her usual shift, but there wasn't anywhere to go anymore. People started spreading rumors that Radio Fresh was over.
努斯拉蒙上了拉埃德的眼睛把他带到了臭名昭著的al-Uqab监狱。他们在电台留下两名武装人员阻止任何人进来。每天，希巴都会做完家务并穿好衣服去换正常班，但已经没什么地方可去了。人们开始散布“新鲜广播”完蛋的谣言。
Days passed. Nusra finally reached an agreement with Radio Fresh. They'd let Raed go and return the equipment, under a few conditions. First, that the radio station wouldn't play music. Here's Raed talking about the agreement. In English, actually, in an interview with the CBC.
日子一天天过去。努斯拉终于与“新鲜广播”达成了协议。他们释放了拉埃德并退还了设备，条件是——第一，电台不能放音乐。这是拉埃德在CBC采访中谈到该协议。实际上，是用英语。
They started to say it's forbidden because it's haram in Islam shariah law. In their opinion, it's haram.
他们开始说这是被禁止的，因为在伊斯兰沙里亚法中这是haram（罪恶）。在他们的观点中，这是haram。
Haram, sinful. Nusra had been on Raed's case about playing music for a while. He's cheerfully defiant.
Haram，罪恶。努斯拉因为放音乐已经找了拉埃德很长一段时间。他愉快地进行反抗。
It was like two years they're asking me to stop playing music, but I refused. Finally, because they attacked the radio station more than three times and kidnapped me like three times--
大约有两年他们要求我停止播放音乐，但我拒绝了。最后，因为他们袭击广播电台超过三次，绑架我也像三次一样——
Kidnapped me like three times, he's saying.
绑架了我三次，他是说。
Then I stopped playing the music, but I started to play sarcastic thing instead of that. Like animal sounds, like sheep, like birds, hogs, dogs, chicken, and everything.
然后我停止了放音乐，但我开始播放讽刺的东西代替。像动物声音，像羊，像鸟，猪，狗，鸡，和一切。
[ANIMAL SOUNDS]
[动物声音]
Animal sounds. Radio Fresh replaced the jingles leading into each segment with animal noises.
动物声音。“新鲜广播”用动物声音代替了进入每个节目的宣传短语。
[ROOSTER CROWING]
[公鸡打鸣]
There was a rooster in the morning.
早上有只公鸡。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
[BIRDS CHIRPING]
[鸟儿叽叽喳喳]
Birds during the day.
白天有鸟儿。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
And after dark, of course--
当然，天黑后——
[CRICKETS CHIRPING]
[蟋蟀叽叽喳喳]
--crickets. The CBC interviewer asked Raed.
——蟋蟀。CBC的采访者问拉埃德。
What's the point of that? Why are you doing that?
这有什么意义？你为什么要这样做？
When the people hear animal voices, they will ask, "what's going on with Radio Fresh?" And the answer will be, the Islamic armed groups banned the music from Radio Fresh because it's haram. I want them just to think, to use their minds. Is it really haram? You can move the minds. You can move the ideas.
当人们听到动物声音时，他们会问，“‘新鲜广播’怎么了？”答案是，伊斯兰武装组织禁止了“新鲜广播”的音乐，因为它haram。我只想让他们思考，运用他们的头脑。它真的是haram吗？你可以移动思想。你可以移动思想。
Nusra's other big demand was for Radio Fresh to take women off the air completely. Raed had a creative fix for this one too. Again, here's Hiba.
努斯拉的另一个大要求是让“新鲜广播”完全把女性撤出直播。拉埃德对这个也有创造性的修正。再次，这是希巴。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
So we were having a meeting, and he came and he told us that they wanted to transform our voices. You know, now we were going to use something to change our voices from female voices to male, and that you wouldn't be able to tell that it was a female in the first place.
所以我们在开会，他过来告诉我们，他们想要改变我们的声音。你知道，现在我们要用某种东西把我们的声音从女性变成男性，而且你无法分辨出那是女性。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
So when we first heard what our voices sounded like, we were laughing. And it was so strange, because we were like, really? This is what people are going to listen to? But after a while, it just became normal, and it literally got to the point where I could tell you which girl was which voice.
所以当我们第一次听到我们的声音听起来像什么时，我们都在笑。而且这很奇怪，因为我们就像，真的吗？这是人们要听的声音？但过了一段时间，它就变得正常了，以至于我能告诉你哪个女孩是哪个声音。
[CHUCKLING]
[轻笑]
But these days, Hiba just feels annoyed at the voice. And because the voice is so hard to listen to, Radio Fresh reduced how long women speak on the air to a fraction of what it was. By this past fall, the Assad regime had retaken swaths of the country. And in many other places, including Kafrenbel, extremists like Nusra were gaining power. People like Raed, people who didn't want Assad or the extremists, they barely held any ground.
但这些日子，希巴只是对这个声音感到烦恼。而且因为这个声音太难听了，电台减少了女性在空中讲话的时间，只有以前的一小部分。到去年秋天，阿萨德政权已经夺回了该国的大片领土。在许多其他地方，包括卡弗兰贝勒，像努斯拉这样的极端分子正在获得权力。像拉埃德这样的人，那些既不想要阿萨德也不想要极端分子的人，他们几乎没有立足之地。
And finally, around Thanksgiving, Raed was assassinated. I read the news in a tweet, and later heard the whole story. He was in a car with two colleagues from the radio station. It was around noon. A van pulled up next to them and shot and killed Raed and his friend Hamoud Junaid, then drove off.
终于，在感恩节左右，拉埃德被暗杀了。我在一条推文中读到新闻，后来听到了整个故事。他在一辆载有两名广播电台同事的车里。大约是中午。一辆货车停在他们旁边并射杀了拉埃德和他的朋友哈穆德·朱奈德（Hamoud Junaid），然后开车走了。
While Nusra never claimed responsibility for the assassination, the whole town blamed them. Everyone I knew who had reported on Syria was talking about Raed that day, posting pictures of him, writing that his death was the end of the Syrian Revolution. Because Raed was one of a handful of people in Syria who was still living by the principles of the revolution.
虽然努斯拉从未声称对暗杀负责，但整个镇都责怪他们。我认识的所有报道过叙利亚的人那天都在谈论拉埃德，张贴他的照片，写道他的死是叙利亚革命的终结。因为拉埃德是叙利亚少数几个仍然按照革命原则生活的人之一。
He was still talking about non-violent resistance and democracy, civil society and freedom. Raed was there from the very first protests in Syria, and stuck by his principles while so many others either died or fell off the train. Now, he too was gone. Hiba got the news over WhatsApp.
他仍然在谈论非暴力抵抗和民主、公民社会和自由。拉埃德从叙利亚的第一次抗议活动就在那里，并坚持了他的原则，而许多其他人要么死了要么退出了。现在，他也走了。希巴通过WhatsApp收到了消息。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
At that point, I just wasn't aware of anything anymore. I never thought that moment was going to come. I never imagined that someone like Raed could die. Like, no, he would be-- he would be one of the ones that stayed.
那时，我简直什么都感觉不到了。我从没想过那一刻会到来。我从未想象过像拉埃德这样的人会死。就像，不，他会是——他会是那些留下的人之一。
The funeral lasted three days. Hundreds of people came. There were programs on Radio Fresh remembering Raed and Hamoud, their childhoods, talking to their friends, chatting about their legacy.
葬礼持续了三天。数百人来了。电台有纪念拉埃德和哈穆德的节目，讲述他们的童年，和他们的朋友交谈，聊天讨论他们的遗产。
After Raed's death, you can still hear glimpses of Radio Fresh's classic dark humor. They continue to make fun of the president and the local factions. Here's a radio drama about a local guy partitioning his house in Kafrenbel to host refugees.
拉埃德死后，你仍然能听到“新鲜广播”经典黑色幽默的片段。他们继续嘲笑总统和地方派系。这是一个关于当地人在卡弗兰贝勒分区自己的房子以收容难民的广播剧。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
But these refugees aren't displaced Syrian women and children. It turns out, no, he wants to host French people fleeing their own country after the Yellow Vest protests, in particular, beautiful French women.
但这些难民不是流离失所的叙利亚妇女和儿童。结果是，不，他想在黄马甲抗议后收容逃离自己国家的法国人，特别是美丽的法国女性。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
"Mary, Sonya, Emily sleeping in the streets? Not on my watch." I found the episode hilarious, a sign that Raed's spirit was well and alive at Radio Fresh. I wondered if Raed's friend, Hadi, felt the same way.
“玛丽、索尼娅、艾米丽在街上睡觉？在我这儿是不可能的。”我觉得这集很好笑，这是拉埃德的精神在“新鲜广播”中很好地存活的标志。我想知道拉埃德的朋友哈迪是否有同样的感觉。
Do you still feel that? Do you still feel that at the radio station?
你仍然有这种感觉吗？你在电台仍然有这种感觉吗？
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
Yeah, I don't think things will be the same again. I mean, despite all my attempts. Meanwhile, we're trying to manufacture a laugh, but our hearts are not the same.
是的，我不认为事情会再一样了。我的意思是，尽管我尽了所有的努力。同时，我们试图制造笑声，但我们的心已经不一样了。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
I don't wanna be pessimistic, but this is the truth.
我不想变得悲观，但这才是真相。
There's a talk that Raed gave two years ago at the Oslo Freedom Forum.
拉埃德两年前在奥斯陆自由论坛上有过一次演讲。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
He opens with footage of the aftermath of a bombing, describing the smell of burned bodies, of guns. The audience is rapt and Raed is gripping. But he also looks very tired of trying to convince these Westerners in peaceful Norway to care about the more than 500,000 Syrians who have died in this conflict and the millions that remain. And yet, there he is. He hadn't given up.
他以轰炸后的残骸片段开场，描述烧焦的身体、枪支的味道。观众很着迷，拉埃德很扣人心弦。但他也看起来非常厌倦试图说服这些和平挪威的西方人关心在这场冲突中已经死亡的超过50万叙利亚人以及剩余的数百万人。然而，他就在那里。他没放弃。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[说阿拉伯语]
He ends his speech saying, "There is nothing prettier than a flower that defies death, chaos, and destruction, and instead blooms and radiates hope. Yeah, just like Radio Fresh.
他结束演讲说，“没有什么比一朵藐视死亡、混乱和破坏，反而绽放并辐射希望的花更漂亮了。”没错，就像“新鲜广播”。
Dana Ballout. She's a filmmaker and a producer at the podcast Kerning Cultures. That's Kerning with a K, Kerning Cultures, which run stories like this one from the Middle East. Last year, Radio Fresh lost its main source of funding when the United States withdrew stabilization aid to Syria. The employees worked without pay for five months. I guess that's what the US government does these days, is just ask people to work without pay everywhere.
达娜·巴卢特。她是一名电影制作人，也是播客“Kerning Cultures”的制作人。那是Kerning，用K拼写，Kerning Cultures，运行像这个来自中东的故事。去年，“新鲜广播”在美国撤回对叙利亚的稳定援助时失去了主要的资金来源。员工们在没有工资的情况下工作了五个月。我想这就是美国政府这些天所做的，只是要求人们到处无偿工作。
Anyway, then they found some temporary funding, but that runs out in March. They're looking for new ways to stay afloat.
不管怎么说，然后他们找到了一些临时资金，但那在三月就用完了。他们正在寻找新的方式来保持生存。
[MUSIC - "WORLD WAR" BY NARCY]
[音乐 - NARCY的“WORLD WAR”]
Our program was produced today by Sean Cole. The people who put our show together includes Elna Baker, Dana Chivvis, Aviva DeKornfeld, Jarrett Floyd, Damien Graef, Michelle Harris, Seth Lind, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Raimondo, Nadia Reiman, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editors-- Susan Burton and David Kestenbaum.
我们的节目今天由肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）制作。组建我们节目的人包括埃尔纳·贝克（Elna Baker）、达娜·奇维斯、阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德（Aviva DeKornfeld）、贾勒特·弗洛伊德（Jarrett Floyd）、达米恩·格拉夫（Damien Graef）、米歇尔·哈里斯（Michelle Harris）、塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）、斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）、凯瑟琳·雷蒙多（Katherine Raimondo）、纳迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）、朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）和戴安·吴（Diane Wu）。我们的总编辑——苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）和大卫·克斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）。
Special thanks today to our interpreters, Saphe Shamoun, Baraa Ktiri, and Hany Hawasly. Also thanks today Dr. Ajay Manhapra, Maia Szalavitz, Andrew Leland, Andy Lanset, Paul Wilson, Neil Verma, Jason Loviglio, Hugh Chignell, Dr. Brian Goldman, Rami Gares, Abdallah Salloum, Abdul wareth Al bakkour, John Jaeger, Isam Khatib, Raja Abdulrahim, and Blueprint Postproduction.
今天特别感谢我们的翻译萨菲·沙蒙（Saphe Shamoun）、巴拉·克蒂里（Baraa Ktiri）和哈尼·哈瓦斯利（Hany Hawasly）。今天也感谢阿贾伊·曼哈普拉博士（Dr. Ajay Manhapra）、玛雅·萨拉维茨（Maia Szalavitz）、安德鲁·利兰（Andrew Leland）、安迪·兰塞特（Andy Lanset）、保罗·威尔逊（Paul Wilson）、尼尔·维尔马（Neil Verma）、杰森·洛维格里奥（Jason Loviglio）、休·奇内尔（Hugh Chignell）、布莱恩·戈德曼博士（Dr. Brian Goldman）、拉米·加雷斯（Rami Gares）、阿卜杜拉·萨卢姆（Abdallah Salloum）、阿卜杜勒·瓦雷斯·阿尔·巴库尔（Abdul wareth Al bakkour）、约翰·耶格尔（John Jaeger）、伊萨姆·哈提卜（Isam Khatib）、拉贾·阿卜杜勒拉希姆（Raja Abdulrahim）和Blueprint后期制作。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to any of our archive of over 600 programs for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to the public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费收听我们超过600个节目的档案。美国生活通过PRX，公共广播交换所，传送到公共广播电台。
Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, last weekend, he and I were up all night, talking in his kitchen. Morning comes, his wife came downstairs, and I don't know. Torey panicked. He just blurted--
一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道，上周末，他和我在他厨房里聊了一整夜。早上来了，他妻子下楼了，我不知道。托雷惊慌失措。他脱口而出——
Oh, we're just girls here hanging out. We're just having breakfast together, morning coffee or a mate.
“哦，我们只是女孩聚在一起，我们只是在一起吃早餐，晨间咖啡或马黛茶。”
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "WORLD WAR" BY NARCY]
[音乐 - NARCY的“WORLD WAR”]